hi my name is Marcus metallic my talk is
about neural networks and their
application to images it's a kind of a
fun talk where we take all the most
recent developments in your networks
like deep dream image classification
retrieval and applied in the
mathematical name framework to several
images and basically it's an imagery
style where we create a second self
portray of Pablo Picasso it's basically
it hi my name is Marcus van I'm second
my talk is about neural networks and the
application to images basically we do
all the fun things that have been done
with neural networks recently in image
processing that is image classification
image retrieval image style transfer
colorization of black and white images
and like the last example which is most
fun I guess is a deep dream that you may
have known or met heard about which was
published by Google alright I understand
that most of you already experts now in
your networks and images after seeing
the results of the competition so maybe
I just don't tell you anything new
anymore
anyhow for those of you not so firm in
newer networks
I'll just take two minutes to explain
all of new your networks just to
establish a little bit the jargon and
then I'll continue okay so the human
brain basically is the idea of a neural
network which we try to imitate and this
is a picture generated in Mathematica of
the visual cortex that does via neural
networks all the image processing that
we do maybe up front just a few little
parameters the brain has 86 billion
neurons about as many trees as there are
in the Amazon forest 5.8 million
kilometers of wiring 202 trillion
synapses connecting those neurons that
is about the number of leaves in the
Amazon forest it can do one Petter flops
of computation probably more
it's hard to estimate and most amazingly
your brain runs in 20 watts so we're not
there yet but maybe we'll get there one
day
okay so that brain function we just
imitate and being a physicist are really
simplified to the utmost possible way
the brain essentially is a function f
with some weights some synapses that you
can change we call them weights W so
these are the parameters of the function
f and you put an input in there a
question visual sensation or whatever X
and you want to have an answer coming
out this is y so essentially all we have
to do is find this function f depending
on Omega mapping X to Y so how do we do
that well first of all in contrast to
what they always tell you in Star Trek
you do need emotions the emotions are
essentially your loss or weight or cost
function because they tell you what you
want to do or what you want to learn and
the emotion in your networks is the loss
function L or the loss layer which you
put around your network and then you try
to optimize or minimize depending on how
you see it
the way it's W for a certain task
minimizing L so that's essentially what
you do training a network the learning
task the hard part and that's done
essentially simply by gradient descent
you try to find the optimum C takes a
gradient walk down the slope and try to
find the minimum with respect to L this
works very nicely because there's a
chain rule so you can take here the
gradient of L with respect of F of W in
there and that's the gradient of L with
respect to F and then the gradient of
the neural network with respect to its
weights and you numerically update that
in steps of Delta W by which you change
the weights by calculating this gradient
not necessarily for all the data but
just for parts of your data which is
then called oh sorry no I'm stuck the B
stands for okay well just for a set of
data not the entire data which makes it
not a precise or exact gradient but
justice to has the gradient and that you
used to learn W by just always changing
W to obtain an object
so that's essentially all of your
networks took three minutes I'm sorry
for that but okay so having established
that we now apply all of this to image
processing and I hope to cover these
five topics image classification that's
a classic in a way I have to start with
that then image retrieval that's the art
of finding image that very much looks
like the image you're looking at without
tagging that's the that's spinning this
then I'll test a little bit and your
networks would generate by doing what's
called dreaming trying to invoke images
in these newer networks do what you all
now know how to do star transfer and
last but not least a dual image
colorization alright so one command that
has been around now for two and a half
years in Mathematica is image identify
and just to remind you of what you can
do I'll take an image plug it in and
hopefully if everything works fine it
doesn't download yeah it doesn't
download a neo Network that's good it
gives you the answer right away it can
be very specific by setting the up
options specific to specificity
specificity go to high and last you get
the tiger but you could also change that
slightly you can set that to low and
then you just say well it's a big cat a
[ __ ] cat or if you want to be very
general you can ask for this to be
animal and all in all you can even get
the probabilities for these kind of
classifications now what is this this
essentially is a very ordinary
classification network which however
does not only map against a list of
classes but on top of that a set of
classes we have a kind of a hierarchy
tree of more entities that we also then
consider as unions of probability unions
of the leaves of that tree and I'll just
quickly demonstrate was basically under
the hood what's under the hood is what
you can upload this net model is this
classification network it's pretty much
a classic
classification network it comes with an
input being the array of image or color
values and pixel values then it does a
convolutional layer does some
normalization as a real uu as an
nonlinear component and then you repeat
doing this and when it becomes a little
bit out of the ordinary is down here
where you don't have ordinary
convolution layers anymore but these are
so called inception layers they are
slightly different a convolution layer
always basically it takes a certain
scales a certain area and tries to
construct a feature out of it but the
problem is that features come in
different sizes if you have somebody
standing close to you is much bigger
feature than somebody far away and
therefore one has to somehow cope with
that effect that you have to let maybe
certain features just walk through
without being processed at that level
and that's exactly what an exception
layer does it basically is a set of
parallel convolutional layers this is a
convolution that layer that basically we
can scroll to it does it
scroll up it's a convolution layer then
you're basically just reduce and have
another convolution layer do it on one
pipeline and then you have another parel
pipeline we just have fewer steps so you
basically take into account that you
have different scales that you have to
process in your in your image other than
that it's very much like the ordinary
convolution layer that you have them for
the m-miss data set okay the next
interesting thing you may wonder about
is how large is this thing and what's
interesting is not only
the thing is unfortunately the whole
thing the definition just went away
after we implement that but I
implemented for you here a parameter
count that counts the number of weights
and biases in a network unfortunately
only the top line is left I just
accidentally apparently deleted the rest
are scrolling through this preparing the
talk while standing here five minutes
ago nevertheless the results are still
here so if I run the parameter count on
this particular network for image
identify you will find that there are 14
million parameters in the network that
have to be trained which then we do for
you so that you can just download the
model and just as a check if you compare
the byte count of the network with the
numbers of parameters you'll see let's
as a relation of 1 to 4 which may
basically means that the parameters are
encoded as 4 byte single-precision
floating-point numbers essentially okay
so having looked under the hood we can
extract if more we can for example see
how they encoder works the encoder
basically always takes a resized image
of 224 times 224 RGB it subtracts a mean
image to just look at the interesting
parts basically color values that are
out of an ordinary dark or bright not
the boring gray and then you can read
off the image size that's being
processed the color space color channels
and so forth the same you can do with
outer encoder and here it becomes a
little bit more interesting because here
you have now a classification you have
labels and the number of labels call to
dimensions and I can call this up and
I'll find out that this particular
network works with 4315 labels and I can
just give you here a random sample of
them printing them all being at entities
takes a while so I just do a small set
and you can see that you can hear it
long beach fern Prairie sunflower and so
forth so very specific entities that
this network can recognize but on top of
this network or this entity list you
have a hierarchy tree which basically is
depicted here not a single tree but a
set of trees I can count through this of
the order of 17 or so and if I just pick
out one of them this is a tree of
locations
so all the end points here are entities
of the classes that I can recognize with
image identify and all the intermediate
nodes in this tree are then super
classes that combine several of the true
leaf classes like here the most general
class is location and that then part is
partitioned into regions or spaces and
the regions are then districts
communities cities slums and so forth
so being sup entities and essentially
when you do image identify you not only
look at the leaves of the classification
but also on the branches that are put on
top of it okay so much for image
identify the our basically main
classification function in Mathematica
and now I'll utilize that function I'm
doing image retrieval so the idea is
pretty straightforward you have an image
like here apparently a temple somewhere
in Greece I guess you run through the
network but you don't run it all the way
to the classification there you stopped
somewhere earlier because you don't want
to do a classification you just want to
get the main features that are somewhere
intermittent in this in your network so
you cut this off which generates then
essentially a feature vector that
feature vector is a point in a K
dimensional feature space and in that
space it just can train a nearest
function calculating what is the nearest
point to the point you just generated
and then you can just find all the
neighboring points and these are most
likely the images that you'd like to
retrieve being very similar and well we
just do this we'll take the net image
identify net that I just generated we
extract only layer one through a layer
global underscore pool which is just
about above the classification level and
then we attach a flattened layer because
that was actually not a flat vectorized
layer but the layer as an array and as
an input we still take images being 24
times 24 RGB and then basically putting
an image in there I get here a vector of
1000 to 24 values
so 1k feature vector and that I can now
use to Wiese it basically generate a
database that I can search visually this
is a very small data set just a data set
of roughly 20 dogs and now for every dog
or image in that data set I have to not
calculate the corresponding feature
point generate a nearest function in
that space and then I can write here
function that basically takes from an
incoming image the feature vector looks
for the nearest feature point in the
date in the feature space just take the
first one and then extracts exactly the
corresponding image from the data set
that I have so that is then my nearest
dot function and we can say see if that
works
I'll just take as a first example of
Retriever hopefully that this helps to
retrieve the image ok so apparently this
work no Yorkshire Terrier yep looks like
it and this seems to be a poodle or a
doodle yeah also seems to work so this
would help to find now certain cars in
your data set or or like by the way this
has been now I've done this artificially
to explain the concept but all of this
also is built into a function that's
called feature extraction so if you're
free to look into that if you don't have
to redo everything I'm doing here ok now
I go into dreaming first just to play
around I don't dream the natural way I
just try to find out what a single
neuron does or what what kind of image a
single neuron really excites so roughly
speaking this is very simplified version
of mine my inception and network I have
an image here which does then be
processed by some convolutional layers
to some linear layer which it's then
fully connected to some classification
layer and what I will do now is
construct a loss function that just
looks if one single neuron a
particularly neuron in the
classification layer here gets excited
and makes sure that all the other ones
are calm and if that's the case if
that's my loss function then I can train
this network
but I don't train all the layers in that
Network I'll just attach another layer
up front which is my image and I only
train that image to be optimal to excite
exactly that single neuron so I'll just
give them the time limit I just scroll a
little bit here fast through the code
sorry for that I know that's always a
little bit annoying so what I do here is
I extract the encoder decoder because I
need parts of it to reassemble that
network that then trains the first layer
okay oh by the way these are the
different classes that I can excite so
it got all the way back down to bathroom
tissues then I have here feature vector
that can i generate from this another
net encoder and this basically is now an
encoder that takes a certain feature
like the neuron for tigers and generates
then a unit vector that is just one here
where the tiger neuron excites and
always zero otherwise and with that I
can then generate down here a feature
loss function that basically is plus one
for all the neurons that are not trying
a minus one for the neuron that is is
tagged and then if these get excited the
one that the tiger neuron gets preferred
to make the loss function go down
furthermore just to get decent looking
images I put in here another loss
function it's called total variation
loss function which basically is the
norm of the gradient of the image which
ensures that I don't have lots of
variations in the image that it has a
certain continuity like natural images
have okay and this generates now a graph
all this it doesn't look good
this generates now a new network that
I'm going to Train and the important
thing is basically here this very first
later layer that's a constant array
layer which I just initiated with some
random numbers and that is basically the
layer that is getting trained and that
is then the image that I will extract at
the end of the training period and so
here I train and the training here it's
just an ordinary training I have the
network I have just as data simply the
order to go for that particular tiger
neuron I balanced here the future loss
and the total variation loss and then
this is important I have here the
learning rate multipliers which tell me
to just mutilate the image and none of
the other network network layers so I
don't train the network but just the
image and I'll do all this on my GPU if
that works fine and just as an
explanation you may have found it out it
is helpful to have a GPU now all the Mac
users are mostly out of luck because
they haven't GPU but not the right one
not an Nvidia one so you cannot run CUDA
and it would help sometimes either to do
it on the internet or you have here an
external a GPU it allows you to train
the network and this would now take a
total of one minute and well roughly two
minutes which I don't have so I'll stop
here but you see it's fine at time and
then this will allow me to extract the
first layer that I just established and
that layer contains the image that I
have already pre computed here and you
see this is a tiger now you might say
well this doesn't look like a tiger and
you're somewhat right but what you can
see a little bit is it
it's full of typical tiger stripes so
essentially it goes and identifies the
tiger but looking for typical stripe
patterns in the image and it also works
in the sense that if I put this image
into my inception Network it says yes
I'm a tiger and then you could of course
goof around make me a tiger so I'll take
my image put a little bit of tiger in it
and then I want to classify myself I is
met oh no that's typical typos lost no
typos changing things okay and okay I go
through as a tiger
alright deep dream apart too quickly
this is pretty much the same story if
there's two modifications here first
I don't excite or yeah look for just one
single neuron firing but I basically
have here a loss function dream deep
dream loss that excites a whole layer so
if a whole layer gets really excited
it's good it's basically when you sleep
and dream your brain starts to process
certain layers start to get active and
then they in a way project onto your
visual cortex then these images that you
see while you dream that's the idea a
little bit then there's one other
modification you saw that I just got
typically just small tiger stripes all
over I didn't have a big tiger a small
tiger so it helps to do all of this at
different scales so I just don't do it
at once care but I do it yet six
different scales so I have a kind of a
pyramid of data I have her to have a
pyramid of nets which makes the whole
thing a little bit more complicated but
feel free to go through this at home and
then last but not least then I can go
ahead and train the network and that in
a sense then modifies and image my input
image being this kind of tree image and
what I get here is this result you can
fool around with it if you excite
different layers in the network you will
see it together that you get different
features for example this layer goes
pretty much for dogs if you take another
layer it's more inclined to go for birds
currently birds have a different number
of features to be combined then dogs and
that's why there's a difference so this
is great fun to play with okay we're
running out of time big boy okay let me
hurry up this I will go through very
quickly now since you all now experts in
style transfer
there are two versions one is the fast
version which basically doesn't encoding
then has a layer that takes the
statistics of one image and imposes
statistics of variation and the mean
onto another image and that gives you
and then it decodes everything and that
gives you a sort of image style transfer
it's not that great so you have seen the
images I guess well let's generate one
here so this is the Manhattan skyline
I love fungo you see there's a
prevalence of diagonal lines there's a
Matisse so or continue ski I think
there's a better way to do it but a more
demanding thing essentially it goes
again a little bit like what we just did
we have here again a network that's done
it's a vgg 16 network where extract
again part of it I just go to a certain
layer I don't call all the way through
so I just want to combine images at a
certain feature layer I don't I'm not
interested in the classification at the
end of the neural network and then I
generate here to loss functions one that
compares the input image and of the
content that I try to preserve and make
sure that what comes out is very close
to the content image so basically this
is an l2 norm comparison between two
images and then to compare styles or to
make stars look alike I have here
statistical loss function that is a
little bit more inclined to the
statistics of mean and variance this is
a ground may trees the ground matrix
where I calculate the correlations
between and the total variations of the
sorry the correlations between two
images or their neighboring points and
here on top of it I didn't have a total
loss function something wrong here and
okay I'll put this into one network
train again here a constant array layer
and I'll just go scroll do three-year
because of money out of
and at the end of the day you then train
the network with the specification you
can give two different weights to the
content loss or the style loss and if
everything works well you then get a
much better impression of the style than
you had before and just one quick
example here
I was just pre calculated this is image
of a Pablo Picasso and style and here I
basically changed the waiting between
loss and content so first I have only
the content original image and I put
more and more style of the painting onto
his image and so it's basically a new
self portray of Pablo Picasso that you
never did actually okay last but not
least one minute to go we have a
conversation Network I'm not sure if
that got introduced this morning the
idea is that you again have here two
networks that go for MIT lab features
and for global features the mid-level
features basically just look what's
there locally on an image as an
education and the global one basically
tries to find out what actually is in
the image is it indoor scene is it a
landscape or whatsoever and these two
then get combined and this combination
then is used to train a layer that comes
up with colors so if you put a black and
white image in there you basically train
here a network that produces the color
that's missing so you can do that very
easily but in color images creating
grayscale and then training the image
that way furthermore you not only have
this lost function but the lost function
with respect to classification and all
of that is here in this color net that
you can download from our net model
repository it consists of all these four
on your networks in there that you can
see here one two three four and then you
can just apply it this is a now function
putting this network to use and so this
grayscale and reconstructing the image
this was original color this is not the
right color
gray oops gray this is the recolored
version so you don't see a big
difference if you look closely though
this is an autumn and the recoloring
didn't get it straight that actually the
colors that we turned orange so it's
missing that or you can take old images
this is an image of my grandfather from
exactly a hundred years ago and put
color into the image so it's great fun
okay so unfortunate time is up there's
one more goodie in here it's a outta
encoder to do denoising feel free to use
it and to figure out how well that works
the idea is basically once you know what
you're encoding you can really well
reduce the noise in an image and this
brings me to the end of my talk just
pointing out that there are two more
talks today one about your network
framework just after this talk by
Sebastian Putin's tiny little chief and
a little later there's his newer
network's workshop for computer vision
also in little chief at 3:30 and then
last but not least come down to the
basement we have a image processing
booth where we can show you all these
things on top thank you
you